يبدو ان تفاصيله واسرار وثائق البانتاجون
المسربه مستمره في الظهور المزيد من
المعلومات والحقائق تتكشف يوميا فبعد
القاء القبض على الجندي جاك تشيع المتهم
الاول بتسريب تلك الوثائق تقرير جديد
لصحيفه
معلومات حول حساب وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تشرف عليه ضابطه سابقه في البحريه
الامريكيه لعب دورا هاما ورئيسيا في
انتشار هذه الوثائق الاستخباراتيه تقرير
يشير الى مدونه روسيه تعرف باسم
وتعني فتاه وهي واجهه لشبكه من حسابات
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي والبودكاست وجمع
التبرعات للموالين لروسيا في حرب اوكرانيا
لكن المثير في الامر ان جنديه امريكيه
سابقه هي من تدير الحساب واسمها الحقيقي
ساره بيلز بيلز عملت في احدى القواعد
الجويه للبحريه الامريكيه وصرحت بانها
تدير الشبكه رفقه 15 شخصا اخر لكنها رفضت
الافصاح عن هوياتهم